hey everybody its Jesse and today I'm
just trying to get more done a lot of
the same thing is yesterday but I did
notice as I was going back through a lot
of these components that they could use
with a little bit of refactoring so
there are some some changes that we made
the components later on that were
beneficial that I never went back and
made those same changes some of the
components that were made earlier so I
am I'm going to go through and I was
just adding an image in here just
putting in some some content to test out
a new component I just made so share the
component in a second
and let me check the I'm gonna check the
live chat here we go I lost my my window
for the live chat so hey everyone
hairy ass what is react react is like a
JavaScript framework it lets you build
web apps and you can build other things
with it too but it's it would be hard to
sum up on a video but just that the very
short answer is it's a JavaScript
framework and it lets you build websites
web apps and actually you can even build
mobile apps and desktop apps very
versatile and actually I think I saw a
talk at a conference that recorded talk
on YouTube about using react to build VR
things which is really cool I don't
really know how to how to do that but I
know people are doing it so hey everyone
alright so I see alright so you got a
bunch of people in the chat now and hey
Thor how's it going I haven't seen you
know uh
I Fernando from Argentina hey thanks for
thanks for watching from Argentina
actually there's a conference coming up
in Argentina that I'm going to submit a
talk for so actually I filled out
everything I needed to submit it and
then I got to the end and it asked for a
video explaining you know a few minutes
just explaining more about the talk and
I couldn't do the video at the time cuz
I was no it was up late all my kids were
sleeping I didn't want to wake them up
by making a video so hopefully I'll get
some time to make that video and I can
apply it would be really cool I've never
never been to Argentina before
if someone in the live chat whose name
is an solo so like Han Solo but without
the age and their avatar is a fixture of
Han Solo so that's pretty cool alright
so I got some questions in the live chat
I guess I'll just answer them now before
we we get started with some of the code
and I'll throw some code up on the
screen just you can see what I've been
working on this is the new component on
this side and it's doing a lot of stuff
I have I did push this up to github so
if you want to check out the code in
more depth it's on the dev branch on
github
but let me just check out few questions
I've epic asked how I load data in page
load and react tree Redux I actually
haven't used redux for anything so I
can't I can't be of much help to you I'm
taking a course right now and I'm gonna
learn more about redux so maybe in
another month or two I'll be able to
answer that question but right now I'm
just not experienced with it so I know
how to load data on page load without
Redux and actually you can you see will
be will be doing some of that probably
during today's stream so I don't know if
that'll be helpful to you but if so you
stick around
well Patrick says there's even a way to
developed command-line interfaces with
react that's really cool I didn't
realize that ek Howard asks I'm
attending a coding bootcamp
and I have to choose between react and
Rails which one well it kind of depends
on what you want to do but I'm I'm
partial to react since I'm using it on a
project now and react seems to be
growing and there's a lot of jobs for
react I don't know the numbers
officially on Rails job sources react
jobs but it seems like the momentum
right now is at least with react so if
your goal is to try to be marketable
then reacts a really good skill to pick
up you can vote a lot of stuff with it I
don't have any experience at all and
working with rails so I can't really
give you great advice since I only know
about react but actually correct me if
I'm wrong is rails is more would Rails
be more back-end isn't that Ruby right
is it and react would not normally be a
back-end type of thing I don't know
maybe I'm wrong like I said I don't know
very much at all about Rails so so
definitely don't take my word for it
okay so it looks like okay I was right
so rails is back-end so there you get so
that's probably the best criteria is
would you rather learn front-end stuff
or back-end so
I guess it would depend on your goals
like do you want to be a back-end
programmer or a full-stack or do you
want to stick with front-end so that's
that's what I would say I would also say
to you know if you're gonna do the react
boot camp then your JavaScript skills
will get a lot better and that can
translate into a lot of different things
not just react so I know my JavaScript
skills have gotten way better since I
started doing things with react whereas
before I was doing a lot of things with
jQuery which jQuery is nice especially
when you're starting out but if you if
you want to be able to easily switch
between different JavaScript frameworks
knowing basic JavaScript is the best
thing so it has really helped me
okay all right so I think I got all the
all the initial questions here in the
live chat so yesterday I tried out a new
system here where I used a Pomodoro
timer to remind me to check the live
chat and then also remind me to stop
talking and do some more code so I'm
going to do that again today I'm gonna
start it as soon as I kind of catch you
all up on what I've been doing
also I I did a stream earlier today on
my own channel so I had a suggestion so
XANA who's not in the live chat yeah I
don't see you in the live chat so maybe
she's not watching right now but she had
this suggestion to do just streams where
I didn't have to worry about doing
commentary or anything but I would just
show what's on my screen and what I'm
working on I had never thought about
doing that before so I thought it was
worth a shot and so I did so earlier
today for about an hour I just showed
what was on my screen I did it on my own
YouTube channel because I wasn't sure I
mean when I was invited to do the
channel on free code or the show on free
code camp it was based on what I
normally do which is a commentary
question and answer and that kind of
thing so I didn't want to just switch
things up and start broadcasting on free
code camp without you know kind of
checking with them first so it was a
little bit spur-of-the-moment so that's
why I just put it on my own channel so
if you're interested in want to check it
out there is a recording of it I'm I
think I'm gonna call the series quiet
coding so I'll probably have like a
playlist on my channel about all my
quiet coding stuff so earlier I was just
doing a lot of like refactoring every
acts of pulling in data from the
WordPress API a lot of the same stuff I
was doing yesterday so I'll probably I
kind of like doing it
had my my microphone muted so I didn't
really have to worry if somebody came in
my office tried to take a phone call or
something I just I could just do it and
didn't it wasn't really a big deal so
not sure if anybody's interested but
just one of the less you know since did
you all gave me the idea for it I want
to let you know that I did try it out
and I don't think I'm just trying to
think if there's any other big things
that happen between yesterday and today
and I don't really think so so I'll show
you what I'm working on right now I'm
just gonna kind of continue on whoops
let me start my start my timer here so I
I was continuing to try to pull in all
the data from WordPress into our react
react site or at least as much as I
possibly could so that it can be
editable within WordPress and nobody has
to touch the code so I went through the
let me just bring that pull the site
over here so I went through some of the
pages finished we had done the about
page already yesterday so I went through
the team page and then now I'm on the
courses page and I'm just pulling in the
data so what I did have to do on this
courses page is make some custom post
type so this section and this section
these are just normal like pages within
WordPress so exactly the same as we have
been doing yesterday with some things
this little section here is just a page
but when we get down to here this now is
a custom post type so before the click
handler was
was actually changing a CSS property to
show and hide this now it's it's not the
click handler is changing the state and
I'll show you in a second and it's
showing or hiding based on that database
on that so it's our you know three
rendering the component so if that
doesn't make sense now it'll make sense
in a second when I show you the code so
these sections and I guess I should
bring I have the live set over let me
bring this over to show you what it did
look like so these sections have images
and they have these links these sections
don't they're just text but they're
similar enough that I thought it's worth
a try to try to make one component that
could handle all these variations
depending on what data gets passed in so
that was that was the goal I wanted I
wanted one component for all of these
things and potentially I suppose the
same component could be used elsewhere
if we ever add pages on so here's what I
came up with so I made a component
called expanding section and I it it has
its own state and it's simply just
display content true or false so really
easy but then I have all these you know
if that we're not really if statements
properly is that you know ternary you
know operators but basically I'm
checking to see if data is there so the
first thing I check for so every section
is going to start out and that be
wrapped in this subsection div right but
the first thing I do right off the bat
is check if there's an image so if
someone in WordPress has uploaded a
featured image to that post
then it's going to render this okay
which is the template that handles
images also once we get down to once we
get down to here so you could you see
from from this part here just handles
that first part this you know this title
once we get down to here this is where
we show our high based on our state so
if state is true then we showed this
part within this part I also have a
section for this link so we're using
that out link component that helps us
track so if you remember we we were
using react what was a react GA so the
google analytics plugin for react and
there was a there was a problem with it
and that it didn't really work properly
if he wanted to set target --blank to
the link so we made our own kind of
wrapper element and it fixed that
problem and that was the show whenever
we actually submitted the pull request
which i've never heard back about that
so not sure really what happened maybe
that project isn't really being
maintained I don't know I never checked
on it maybe I'll ask about it if I get a
chance it's possible that I know I
didn't properly follow the the rules for
testing so it's possible that maybe when
they saw that they just didn't even look
at it but we'll see I think it's worth
checking up on again because there are
other people that had a similar issue so
this could be helpful but anyway if
there is a URL added in to our custom
post type which I thought I had it on
the screen maybe I moved it over
oh yeah I did so we can see like the URL
here so if a URL is entered then this
button gets rendered otherwise it does
it doesn't so the other variation then
is and then of course it displays our
image here the other variation is just
the text with or without the link okay
so there are potentially right now for
variations that could happen on this
this component so we could have image
text and a link we could just have text
and image we can just have text or we
could have text with a link I'd like to
add one more variation because right now
we alternate so I need one more
variation to just flip these and
alternate so this isn't going to be
something that the content manager from
WordPress picks I could make it another
field to set whether it's right or left
but I don't really think that that's
important I can it's possible maybe that
they would want to do it but in general
these types of sections look better if
it does alternate so I think I'm just
gonna make it so that it always
alternates and that can't be changed and
I'm more comfortable with that then that
way I don't have to rely on whoever is
changing the content to realize that it
looks better
you know alternated so that's one less
thing for them to worry about and it'll
keep the same look that that we wanted
with this alternating thing here this
woman here actually works at Franciscan
she's super super nice everything every
web said I do she always says it's
really really great and she
loves everything I do so anyway most of
these pictures in here these aren't like
stock photos these are real people from
the University which is cool because
normally I work a lot with stock photos
this is actually a chapel that's on
campus it's a replica of one in Italy so
anyway a little side note all right so
that's it sort of to finish up this
component we just want to make these
alternate so the good thing is we don't
have to make a whole nother section
where we change the HTML at least I
don't think we do I'm pretty sure that I
can just change let me see how I did it
because I did do you use some the way I
I laid out this grid with the CSS I made
some custom classes that can change the
order of where these things are so I'm
hoping that that's all I'll need to
change if if I can't exactly remember I
set this up because I set it up months
and months ago on a different project
and I just carried it over but if it
doesn't work like I wanted to then I can
just make this component a bit bigger
and copy and paste everything over and
then we'll make we'll figure it out but
for right now I think it'll be it'll be
ok we just need to check out so I guess
the easiest way to test this would be
I'm going to go here we can see now for
this one we have text on left image on
right so what I want to do is change I
don't know if this is gonna work I'm
gonna give you shelter I'm gonna change
this order I think my order CSS might
only work on a small screen now that I
think about it yeah it does ok I think I
have it so that it only works on small
screens screens right now so that the
image always ends up being on top so let
me just make sure that's still working
like that yeah there we go so this only
goes like that all right so the solution
then I assume that this is like I'm
using a media query to make it so that
that only applies here trying to think
of what the most the best way to make
this happen would be
I can put off thinking about it for just
a second because what we need to do
anyway is we need to figure out which
basically whether it's odd or even
number alright so and this is not hard
and we're probably going to need to do
it here when we actually I'm sorry not
where am I here we go so when we
actually set up and and start going
through this component this is where we
need to do it so we need to we need to
get the index number and then pass it
probably will pass it as a problem I
think that's the best way all right
so if you're not sure what I'm talking
about right now it'll be obvious in a
second when I actually do it so what I
need to do now is get the index number
and I'm wondering I don't know if I have
to put a bracket there now I'm gonna try
it without the bracket hopefully I can
do it otherwise I'll put a bracket in
and now I need to put the index equals I
and then let me save that and find out
okay no errors that's good and did it
render yeah it's still rendered okay
great so we're gonna grab the index
we're gonna pass it as a prop to our
component now within our component let's
I'm wondering if I if I ought to put
something in state basically all I need
to do is be able to tell if this is odd
or an even number I don't think there's
necessarily any value in putting that in
state we're never gonna have a need to
change that after the fact all right so
I think we can we can change this I
don't really need to do anything else
with this with this index so let's
change it here might be easier now we'll
leave it here and then we won't have to
rewrite a lot of this logic and really I
don't know if we'll do it it might just
be a little nitpicky to do this right
now but really I should probably put as
much of the logic that's going on here
into the components and make it easier
to put things in but some of it I think
I actually do have to do here to avoid
getting some error messages but for now
let's move this in here and just say
let's say is even I don't know that I
even really need to make a component for
this or I mean it's like a separate
function I could probably do it in line
but others do it here
that's the right syntax right I don't
know why I write this so often I don't
know why I'm second-guessing it but I
guess it's like when you look at a word
that you spelled a million times and it
just looks weird to you all of a sudden
like you spelled it wrong so let's say
index this drops index and I'm going to
say oops
if it equals I always forget I always
have to double check what the correct
with the true and false values are for
the answers so so what is it like if
it's 2 modulo the modulus operator and 2
we get zero so if it's 3 I'm on my other
screen I'm just doing a little bit of
math ok so that's how it is so what we
want so if it equals zero then we're
gonna return true because it is even
otherwise oh yeah that's right that
makes sense I gave me that I had to do
the math to figure that out but
sometimes this is this easier to just do
the math
make sure okay that is gonna come
through as a number all right so
basically what this is doing if you're
not familiar with this operator what
this does is give you the remainder of
what's left over once if you were to
divide this number which is our index
number by two the it'll give you the
remainder so if it's divisible by two we
will have no remainder which is y of 0
if it's not divisible by 2 we will have
a remainder so that's that's where where
all this is coming from and I don't know
why I'm getting such weird syntax
highlighting did I do something wrong
so I'm gonna check my time here and make
sure I do check the lodge at oh okay
I'm glad I checked the live chat because
I'm Berto has just told me correctly
that why do I need the true or false
couldn't I just do this and it would
return true or false I'm better you are
correct and also who else Pedro gave
that answer as well and and I messed up
the arrow function thanks Patrick
goodness
all right so this is a lot better now
oh hey zan is here now Zanna were you
here earlier when I was talking about
doing the stream earlier based on your
idea from like yesterday or maybe was
two days ago
if not I'll say it again really quickly
all right in the in the live chat I'm
just gonna read through a bit since I'm
I've already kind of paused the bet here
John Hanson says I sort of knew a bit of
jQuery for about a year then halfway
through a project I thought myself your
regular JavaScript
not bad for sixty never too late to
learn yeah that's awesome
actually I think I mentioned this before
but my dad is 57 I think and he's going
to retire this year and I'm trying to
convince him to learn a little bit of
front-end development and so I'll have
to tell them that that it's not it's not
too late to learn
the Indra has a question how to avoid
rear-ending all react tap wind state
change and rendering only children so
and then there's some clarification
Nikola is asking what kind of state are
you talking about component internal
state or something like Redux andrew
says talking about the big app state
want to do it without Redux or flux or
set state as simple member and passes
props to children okay so Nicola says
any component that has its props change
will rerender itself meaning if your top
components props or state changes
everything underneath it will rerender
okay yeah so I would say without seeing
the code Andrew yeah if you could keep
if it's possible to have like keep some
state you know within a component that
would reduce re-rendering everything if
you could I'm not really sure I don't
know I don't know that I can give you a
great answer if it's possible for you to
like link to a github repo or something
you can like send me a direct message on
Twitter or something like that with the
link if you don't want to link it in the
live chat and then I could try to check
it out when I get a chance
Gunnar's says hey Jesse hey gunner how's
it going thanks for watching okay John
Hanson says flex bucket flex block box
added a class that can easily change the
dome order flex direction row or row
reverse so you may not get the toggle
left right if the viewer skips one
heading
all right lift it shake I have to check
that out as soon as I get this basically
the next step will be whether I want to
handle this like with CSS or whether I
want to actually make another component
so Zanna I just looked at the link that
you posted that had pictures of dogs
with squishy cheeks oh that's that's uh
that's pretty cool made me smile so
here's some examples here for you all
later watching
let me see
all right so we had a Cathal asks what
theme do you use for Adam I use the SETI
theme SETI
Oh Sebastian's already answered that
sorry I do that all the time you think I
would have learned by now to read the
next few comments before I answer yeah
now I can see that everybody noticed
that I messed up my error function
before I noticed
yeah so this is a Pomodoro so I had a
question here in the live chat about the
Pomodoro yeah so this is a poem of over
timer so what I'm gonna do is use this I
use it all the time when I work but I'm
gonna use it during the be live streams
now to give give me a better idea of
just the time when I'm working and also
you know every time the timer goes off I
will remind me to check the live chat
and then after the five minutes is up
it'll remind me to go back to coding so
I broke off from that a little bit early
this time because I suspected that I was
doing something wrong anyway so I
figured you all would have caught it
let's see ok Nicholas but is there a
reason you're not setting your initial
component state inside the constructor
she talks oh I'm not sure
are you talking about this component
here
so oh wait there's a little bit of delay
oh wait so Nicola let me know if if I'm
in the right spot there also anyway
Zanna I think I had asked if you had
heard what I said earlier but then I
didn't see whether or not you answered
me there's a lot of stuff going on so
I'll just say it so you had the idea a
couple of days ago of me just doing like
a quiet stream with I didn't do any
commentary but I I just would do my work
and you could watch the screen so I
actually did that this morning on my own
YouTube channel for about an hour and I
think it worked out pretty well I didn't
have that many people watch it but that
was okay because I really liked I didn't
I couldn't handle if people were asking
questions and stuff because I was just
trying to get the work done so anyway I
think I'll do that more frequently I
think that was that was actually a good
idea and I was able to keep my normal
workflow and my normal pace it didn't
really bother me knowing that the screen
was being recorded so so that was a
really good idea and I'll do those on my
YouTube channel not on free code camp
and less like someone from free code
camp asked me and says they really want
me to do that but otherwise I'm just
going to keep doing this this kind of
stream for free code camp and then I'll
do the quiet stream on my own channel
okay Nick alright that makes a lot more
sense that one so anyway Nicholas
question about the constructor was
because he was just joining didn't
realize that the component or I'm sorry
that that the entire thing was done in
in next j/s so
let's see alright I think I got through
all the questions
okay I see Sebastian had me copy and
paste something but now I see I'm just
gonna I'm going to avoid the potential
copy and paste like invisible character
errors going on here so I think this is
exactly what you had
so it's even equal zero this problem and
X modulo two equals zero okay so that's
cool
thanks Sebastian it's always crazy it
like never fails that things that you do
frequently that work when you're not
being watched somehow you seem to mess
up when you are was so anyway that's
just the way it is all right so we have
this now so so now we know whether or
not this particular instance of that
component is even or odd and okay
there's my timer so I will say two I
have I have a few things that are like
not coding related that I do need to get
done before I leave and I have a meeting
at 5:00 so I need to make sure that I
have enough time before then to do this
stuff so actually one of the things that
need to get done I can probably do on
the stream so I'm just telling you all
mostly so that I hear myself say it and
I don't forget but if maybe if one of
you also remember you can remind me if I
forget towards the end of the stream so
I need to make sure that I actually
changed the links or tomorrow
the site is going live that this one
links to so I think I I think I have it
up here somewhere so it doesn't really
matter so the learning management system
that this site needs to link to is going
to be live tomorrow it's already live
right now I don't know if you can log in
or sign up for courses yet but at least
the homepage works so I'm just going to
link to it today so
don't have to work on it tomorrow so I
need to do that before I leave so I
needed to switch to the master branch
add the link in the proper place and
then push the code to both of our our
servers and make sure it works before I
leave today the other thing I have to do
is get some data to the head of my
department so that she can use it for a
meeting that she has on Monday which oh
I won't be here on Monday I'm gonna take
my kids to an amusement park
and so no stream on Monday but I will be
back Tuesday
alright so having haven't gotten that
out of the way
let's sort this out now so
let's see at this point
I kind of just want to
I kind of want to just put just take
just this section because that's all
that would really need right just this
section and just say like you know if
it's if it's even do it this way if it's
all do it that way so I will just copy
and paste this which kind of stinks
because I don't like to repeat it so
much the same stuff but I know like John
said that you can do this with Flex box
but since I haven't done stuff with Flex
box like that at least for a while
it'll be faster for me to just switch it
around so let me do that now so this
date display content so if we are
displaying content and let's say n is
even don't need up front you do this is
even right this is even then we're gonna
do it this way yeah we want the first
one to be like this so because the first
one will be zero so that'll give us a
zero so that'll register is even okay
and then
I don't know I can't I don't want to do
it like that I'm sure you all realize my
my mistake
so no cuz I wanted to either display or
not display so what I want to do is make
another one inside of this one so
I always want the image to have order 1
so I'm going to go through I don't know
if this will give me an error or not but
it won't take me that long to try it so
someone else will try if is even
you do this
else
why did I just copy that again that was
silly
I also gonna do this and then I'll
simply flip this around so it's really
ugly now but it'll all get Auto
formatted in a minute oh I was so
terrible
and I need I swim
there you go
okay uh based on the highlighting this
is looking weird I'm not sure to work
but yeah it doesn't work okay Isis she's
arrived in closing today
yeah I need I don't know that that's
gonna work
alright I'm gonna check the live site so
I'm sure you all have been giving me
advice while I'm doing this phone this
is this seemed like it would be the
fastest way it looks like it's a mess
but basically the reason it didn't work
is because I now then have adjacent
elements that aren't enclosed in one
element and you can't do that in react
so if I want this to work I either need
to wrap this in a div which may or may
not mess up the formatting it's worth a
shot to try I suppose or I need to go
out like another level here and you know
do this but I'm not
anyway I'll check the live chat see what
you all think
that's what Susanna's comment about me
always being polite okay she said I
could just do talking for like 20
minutes at the end or after each 20
minutes yeah that's what idea I think
was to do like after each like big
Pomodoro session to then take a few
minutes to talk yeah we'll see yeah I'll
try it out and see kind of what the best
mix is I did I used to have the idea of
just waiting until the end to do all the
QA but the problem is if there are too
many people in the live chat the the
questions that they asked at the
beginning get they get deleted they're
just there's like a limit so I can't see
them anymore so then now I take a few
times throughout the stream to check
questions okay so all right so say this
here need some advice here it says says
I should I won't be able to please
everyone because I always try to talk to
everyone so better focus on the
questions related on what you do at the
moment and answer the others at the end
or find a way that works for you yeah
you're right that's that does make sense
to try I do i do get sidetracked I I try
I guess to save some of those questions
for the end but I do occasionally get
sidetracked and the reason being like
especially if I see someone who's new I
haven't seen the chat before even if
they ask an unrelated question I really
do like to answer them before they leave
the chat because I want everybody to
feel welcome like after for those of you
that I see a lot I know you're not gonna
get upset if you know I'll wait to
answer your question to a little bit
later because I mean you understand like
I'm trying to actually get some code
done as well so anyway that's why I get
sidetracked so I kind of
feelings about that I do think it would
be easier to follow the stream for you
all and I would get more work done if I
didn't you know take those little those
little side trips to talk to people but
I also I do think it's important because
I mean you never know they somebody some
people come on and say I just started to
learn how to code yesterday and I don't
want them to get discouraged you know
when they're you know when they're just
starting out I mean oh it could if they
feel like they're being ignored and they
just started maybe it took a lot of
courage for them to pose so anyway maybe
I'm thinking too much into it but I
would rather I would rather not be the
person that is the reason why they quit
coding or or just have a bad day so but
I'll probably as more and more people
watch this and chat I probably will have
to come up with a better way to make
sure that I stick to things because
they'll just be way too many questions
maybe I'll have to get like a moderator
or something in the chat and they'll
pick out the questions or something
okay so John has an idea this is back to
being related about to our problem at
hand John says could you use an event
listener on click to those headings and
then toggle like flip the order based on
that okay so I don't I don't actually
think we need to to change it on click
no I don't think we need to because we
still it would basically be the same the
same problem either way we just need to
have like just a slight variation here
another set so whether or not we're just
checking for even or odd or were we're
adding in a click there I think if we
added the click we would still need to
know whether it's even or odd am I
missing something
am I missing some reason why we should
have a click handler involved in this as
well so let me know class thing and I'm
getting I'm getting distracted again in
the live chat a Sebastian just talked
about the YouTube dark theme yeah if you
haven't tried out the dark theme on
YouTube try it out so you got you all
know that I am a fan of the dark theme
so I really like it I have found that I
did have some things that just weren't
working right because it's a newer UI
and everything so I did switch back to
the
the light theme because I couldn't like
respond to comments on videos for some
reason so it's probably fixed now
alright so here's what I'm gonna try I'm
just gonna wrap this in a div hopefully
this won't mess things up I'm just I'm
worried that it'll mess up or something
with the knee of the column classes and
like the grid system and with
materialise but I think it's worth a try
so we do a div here and then what do we
need
hmmm I think I messed up somewhere and
pasting yeah I did
okay yeah I did myself because that
should not be there and then yeah so
this this is the right spot no is it no
it's not alright I'm gonna I got to
think for a second so I can figure out
what how I mess these divs up all right
so this all right goes all the way up
here with that so then we need a div
inside directly inside this one
right
yeah okay so we do need a div that's
gonna be I guess here
this will need that death we may not
need let me see what this one is okay we
do need that device so we're good on
those - these two are necessary within
this we're probably gonna need some sort
of enclosing just yeah we needed we need
a div here to close this column I don't
know how I messed this up so badly yeah
this has to be close it should have paid
more attention when I was copying
pasting originally all right so that's
there this is the outline
Oh actually I don't need it there I need
it there should be here there we go okay
so that didn't need to go there and then
this whole thing ought to be wrapped in
closing div all right
so we need so it's the class name div no
I don't need I don't need this but I
need one down here this kind of thing
takes the most brainpower it seems like
for me than anything just figuring out
where I messed up this is this same
problem happened to me a few hours ago
do you think I would have learned my
lesson at least it was easy for me to
figure out the problem now since this
happened before okay I think all the
divs are in their proper places now yes
all right awesome
hmm all right so that one didn't have
why is this doing this so this is not
working the way we wanted to I'm gonna
refresh okay we'll see so the Maya dev
server did quit working so I'm not gonna
now don't worry until I get it back up
and running I actually did take time
this morning and try to figure out why
my dev server keeps stopping and I
couldn't figure it out I thought like
well maybe I should update node on my
machine which I did I updated it which
is probably I probably needed to update
it anyway but the update did not fix it
so I tried looking up the error on line
and I found some other people that had
the same error and the solutions it it
didn't work so there were three issues
on github about that error but for other
nothing with next j/s so it's probably
not an XJS problem two of the
issues never got resolved and then the
third issue the the resolution was just
I tried a few things in it but a lot of
it like just wasn't really applicable to
my situation so anyway the end result
was that the time I spent on it I only
succeeded in upgrading node but I did
not succeed in solving the problem so
let me check out I'm gonna inspect this
and my dev tools is on one of my other
screens right now which I'll bring it
over if I need to okay so it seems like
wrapping that div around everything is
not it's not gonna work which that
stinks because I said judge took a lot
of effort to make sure all my dad's
messed up okay
all right so here's what I'm gonna try
this son let's take out these divs now
I'm gonna try to be very careful when I
take these out so I don't mess things up
again so there's one and there's the
matching one okay and I just need to do
that one more time so this is a div so
there's one and there's the matching one
okay great so I'm gonna I'm just going
to confirm that I'm getting the same
error yep same air okay so we're back
kind of where we started and here's my
idea for a solution right now so I think
what I'll do is I'm gonna try to add in
I'd say I want to try this is I just
want to see if it's possible I don't
feel like looking it up I'd rather just
just do it here's what I want to try I
want to I want to do
I want to try to put a ternary inside
that's her name
there's no way there's no way this will
work but I think it's cool to try all
right so I am gonna need a closing div
here and now I'm also gonna need another
closing div here and let's see display
content so this even so within this all
right so this is our alternate and then
we go down here and
which they're closing trying to find out
where our other ternary actually closed
I guess it's not there it was there but
I don't think that's doing anything okay
all right let's see what errors we get
all right that's not what I was
expecting
let me see what I did
oh I have a div I don't need any more
right
if I want to be really excited this
actually works it works all right I'm
pretty sure we're gonna add in like one
more thing just to double-check but we
didn't get an error like all right so
check this up it is in fact possible to
nest turn Aries and it works it looks a
bit messy it's like a lot of mental
effort to keep it all straight for me
and it's probably giving a mess if I
ever want to come back in here and
change it so I don't know that I would
ever recommend it or do it again but it
definitely works that's really cool I
though that was fun I don't know if you
all what you all think about it but it's
sometimes it's fun to just do things
even if you're not sure if it'll work
all right I'm gonna check the live chat
really quick because I'm sure that that
some of you had something to say about
what I was doing
did my a actually that was great timing
all right so I'll do my five minutes now
or the live chat
let's see okay so John said I have asked
before if I was missing something about
why we should have a click Handler and
John said it's because what if a person
skips one or two or three headings will
not add an even order in those headings
along with the open and close elements
oh I see what you're saying now
all right so sorry I didn't get that
until now so basically the idea was so
yeah if everything's open in order let
me use this one for an example so if
everything does get open you know in
order you get the audio in effect right
it's nice but what if somebody just
skips right so you have to line up here
so I hadn't thought about that I think I
actually don't think the effect is is
bad when there's this gap and there's
obvious that there's another one in
there because I'm thinking basically
what would end up happening I think
would be more jarring than this so that
if I had these open like this and then I
opened this one I guess it honest on a
shorter screen it didn't really make a
difference but if you could see them
both what you would see happening is
this one would open up here and then
this one would flop it what this would
flip flip flop right here so I think I'm
okay with this happening
but that's definitely a good thought I
didn't even occur to me at all yeah so I
think I am going to leave it like this
but I appreciate I appreciate the
thought and you're explaining it to me
since I didn't understand right away
no man I never noticed this picture is a
little bit old so this isn't there we
get a new food service vendor for the
for the University and I don't think
that this is the name of this coffee
place anymore so I'm surprised nobody
noticed because my boss is usually like
he notices every little detail like that
she must not actually looked at this
picture cuz I bet he would have noticed
it I don't think it's the big deal but I
think we usually like to not make
anything in the image that could give a
date so that people don't realize like
hey we're using like really old images
or something in our sights anyway let me
put in one more I'm gonna put in the
data for let's see yeah I want to put in
the data for one more so that I can
actually see if we're getting the
correct ordering happening because right
now I really I can't tell
so think the only one is crucification
kind of context
FastTrack okay so this is the only one
that I haven't put in yet so I'm
entering this into WordPress oops
and I should probably while I'm doing it
I should probably just put in this link
like it's supposed to be
okay sorry about this this is boring
stuff but I definitely think you need to
test this before I move on so I was I
was pretty sure it wasn't gonna work and
so since it did work I'm very I'm still
a little skeptical since its appearing
to where I Creighton huh
it's made this image the other nice
thing is that when I get all these
images into WordPress I can take them
out of the the react app so they don't
need to be stored on the same server
right now they're not in gonna be
tracked and get anymore so it'll make
everything just a little bit smaller
oh man that's huge image I need to go in
and
sorry I just lost my train of thought
right in the middle oh I need to go in
and get better image sizes for this this
was on my list of things to do and then
I got pushed pushed into doing some
other things and never got back to doing
the images okay
so let's refresh and we should have
everything nope
all right so I'm really glad I did that
because we are not getting the
alternating like we want did I actually
change the order of these yeah I did
okay so this definitely has us a
different order all right so what's
going on
alright I'm gonna check the chat really
quick to see if anyone has any ideas if
I'm missing something
oh yeah Sebastian did say about the dev
server it is definitely just this
machine because I can use it on my my
laptop and the repo works fine and the
dev server is fine so I don't know what
is going on with my machine
okay Patrick addict the idea to refactor
those these chunks so I'm assuming you
meet within this within this componentry
fact there are a lot of this stuff that
I'm repeating into stateless components
and then that way it'll be a lot easier
to read yeah you're right when I first
was doing this I didn't think it would
get this this huge but maybe I should
just make those into components now and
yeah that will be so much easier Todd
John says Jesse you live on the edge you
only learn by being fearless I like that
thanks Jeff yeah I mean what like what's
the worst that could happen I just get
an error message right and then I just
you know hit hit ctrl Z or command Z and
then it's all good it's back to normal
again and I'm using you know get as well
so I could just go back to previous
commit so why not like it's not like I
can it's a local deficit might as well
try out whatever I want
John I saw you just said he said it
could be jarring meaning like the
back-and-forth that I was talking about
with the order unless you he said unless
you animate JK's yeah I always I always
think it'd be cool to animate things and
I would like to do it but I just like
don't have time right now
only because like you all know like I
need to be done with this project by
neck like by the middle of next week
so there's definitely things that
definitely things that I would like to
do that I'm just not gonna be able to do
Sode is asked a few questions hey
welcome to the channel I don't think
I've seen you in here before so welcome
this is we're using JavaScript and it's
in particular to react the react
framework in JavaScript and sawdust can
you teach me and want to be an expert in
programming languages please can you
teach me well if you watch this you'll
get some idea of what my job is like so
it's not exactly like a teaching like
tutorial based thing I am gonna release
some videos on my own channel hopefully
sometime soon if I can quit having these
crazy deadlines and those will be more
tutorial oriented if you have any
specific questions or want me to check
out your code you can direct message me
on Twitter and I'll try to check
everything out when I get a chance
yeah and Sudd said would you say PHP
yeah so I did a little bit of PHP for
this a custom plugin for WordPress so
everything else has been JavaScript
okay so Sebastian is giving me some
alternate syntax that may be able to
help me out here
okay
and see let me let me show you
let me show you some of what is being
pasted in the live chat so I said didn't
didn't catch everything so something
like this
okay so let me so I'm getting some some
good advice here in the chat so let me
let me go back in here and let's try to
do so basically I don't need to nest my
statements or wait let me see what
school
all right so basically this is this
syntax is is saying I just want to make
sure I had it right before I told
everybody's sorry for the pause saying
if it even then do something else don't
do anything so you're saying basically
so I can basically get rid of like areas
where I'm using like the question mark
and the : I'm trying to find an example
oh if I'm on the wrong page that's why
sorry yeah so like normally I use the
question mark and then the : here so I
wouldn't need to use those then but I
think in this case I I do need the else
right so for like for this if it's even
I need to render this if it's not even
so I need that else I neither under this
correct
now for these ones I could try that out
for these ones right because I'm
rendering nothing here so I could get
rid of
so and so this
so like for this one I could do this
props URL oh actually I don't know if I
could do it because I'm not checking for
true or false here I'm checking to see
if it's if it's blank so this was
probably only work if what I'm checking
for would be true or false if I'm
checking for anything else then I
couldn't miss I might not be able to do
it or could I still do it but I would
just have to put the end right here
all right so let me let me share this
and then I could do this
alright cool let me just see because
this should I'm pretty sure that that
part of the template is the one the only
one is rendering right now cool really
cool I don't know what this this should
actually have a link in it I want to
double check to make sure that the link
is there
I guess I never put put the link in so
it should have one
okay
I'm gonna get rid of these as well
inside here cuz I don't I don't want to
see the doubles anymore
that'll shorten this up a bit - okay
okay
let's make sure Ricky
okay
let me bring over it's a little awkward
right now I had my terminal underneath
this the window that I was the live chat
was on so I'm gonna bring it over bring
it over here so you all can see what I'm
doing on the terminal as well
okay son I see I see you gave me your
email they're just uh do you have a
github profile where you have your codes
so you could give me the link to that
then I could check that out also all the
links to all my social media stuff are
linked up somewhere in the description
this video some are links from my
youtube account so you can you could
contact me in a variety of ways but if
you want to send me a link to your
github then then I can check that out
okay cabbie and says the the empty
string is false II so I don't even have
to have that so where was I at here so I
should be able to just do this right
yeah I just thought the same thing
Patrick so Patrick put in the live chat
you titled this refactoring you're
getting a lot of refactoring advice yeah
I accept itíll this refactoring because
I wasn't sure what else to call it but I
was only billing some refactoring but I
thought I don't think I've ever titled a
video refactoring so let's let's do that
and now it's it it's actually nearly
entirely refactoring at this point so it
was appropriate Oh Patrick just had a
good idea saying that I should try
cloning into a new directory on my
machine to see if that will fix the
server issue I'll have to try that I I
had not tried that yet so I'll try that
out if that works that will be awesome
all right let me let me see all right so
did I say that let's see make sure that
really works
okay cool whoa
did you all see this somehow I'm getting
the images now right how is this rule
where are these coming from they are in
fact coming from WordPress so I don't
know what I did I didn't do anything but
now all of a sudden the images are
working and you've seen that like they'd
never work locally they'd always oh well
I'm not complaining all right so
basically what we need to do then is
figure out why it's not flipping the
order like we wanted to and rendering
this other thing maybe my nested ternary
operator just does not work and that's
certainly possible we could also let's
see
I said only to let me um I'm gonna check
on dev tools and I'll bring this over to
the other screen now since it may be
beneficial for everyone to see this so
I'm gonna check on dev tools and see
what exactly the props are that are
being passed here to make sure we're
getting the right index okay so this one
has an index of one so we should be
getting okay this was index zero all
right so it looks like the index yeah
that's that's what we want so we should
be getting like true and false
alternating but we're not all right so
let's put in
oops
this oh no I forgot this I even made
sure that I use the arrow function so
that this would work okay cool so now
we're getting what we need so we have
false true false true false
who
so we're getting a value
so then the problem is we can at least
move down here and see maybe it's within
our return area
just can't show those persons
okay our bad I see since you've been
using this props URL a number of times
[Music]
so I can D structure that to Const URL
this props
yeah I probably could do some D
structuring I'm gonna I'm not gonna do
it right now because if I turn these
into I want to see like how much I can
reduce the usage of it by turning these
into their own components
okay so let me see
I was just reading I'm reading all the
the advice here and the live chat I
probably should have read it out loud
sorry to everyone who had to sat through
that silence I think someone mentioned I
should be calling it like that
oh that was it all right let me let me
figure out who said that so I can thank
you properly I can't believe I miss that
heavy in art so Kevin thank you so much
so here's the problem I was using this
even this is even instead of actually
calling it like that and that was it
that was the problem it's crazy because
I even did it the right way up here so
really good catch with that one awesome
so now our even odd thing is working and
I need to switch the order of this but
I'm not gonna do it on the stream
because I'm actually gonna do it in
WordPress I'm just gonna change the date
the published date of this to make it
publish after and then everything will
be in the right order all right awesome
so this is the this needs to be
populated with a huge list but I'm not
worried about that now I might I might
not even do it myself I might have the
Amy who's doing the content management
put all that that data in I should
probably have her do some of this anyway
and then that way it'll be like training
for whenever I'm not working on this
anymore all right awesome
so the courses page works now we should
probably clean this mess up
alright so I'm gonna let me get rid of
this I don't need this
but I'm gonna commit this because it
works and then we'll refactor and if I
make a big mess of everything at least I
will have a working version that's been
committed that I can always go back to
whoa okay I gotta get rid of I
originally had different components for
each one of those before I changed my
mind and did it in just all one
component so
there we go
also this is no I was gonna say it'll
make everything look nicer and it'll be
easier to work with where do we add
please fix them okay I forgot to remove
that that's an easy fix
so I was directly using out link and
since I moved it into this component I
don't need it anymore so that was the
the air there so let's do that again
great all right looks like I have an
update for NPM available
all right cool so while that does this
thing
let's work on this oops
okay so first of all first of all oh I'm
gonna try to figure out what should be
put into its own stateless functional
component and so basically things that
I'm I'm repeating are really good
candidates or potentially things that I
might not be repeating now but I could
see you needing to repeat elsewhere
somewhere else on the site are also good
candidates for this
all right so let's see
I guess this could be
this probably could be I'm kind of
hesitant because I don't really want to
do the work of doing the click and then
sending the data back and all that so
let's we'll see oh I mean I'll do it if
it really seems like I obviously should
do it let me see how many times I use
that twice
actually that is a really good candidate
I think because I potentially this could
be used in other parts of the site too
all right let's do it
the reason I didn't want to do it is
because I have done it before where I I
have a clique that changes state and
apparent component but I've only done it
like twice and so I'm not real sure
about it so since I've already messed up
so much on today's stream I'm not in a
hurry to do it again but oh whoa I guess
there's only it's the only one way to
really learn something and remember it
and that's to keep doing it in practice
so let's do it I definitely need to
change the song I'm listening to it
because it's really annoying
all right
let's see so we're gonna call this
component
I'm trying to get a name for this
component try to name it like based on
what it does since it's gonna have a
click handler basically it's gonna show
hi but it doesn't necessarily have to
show hide the click could do other
things it really it makes sense with the
way we're handling this SVG that it is a
show hide but it doesn't necessarily
have to be
so I guess I'll just call it click
heading alright cuz it's it's an h3 tag
it's a heading and you click it yeah cuz
a lot of stuff I could potentially make
a lot of the stuff in here changeable
based on the props so it could be pretty
versatile alright so let's do that let's
call it click heading Oh what happened
oh I shoulda used to - wait what's that
I remember someone gave me the advice of
how to use the command to use if you've
accidentally run something that you
should have run in sudo and there's a
way to run it in sudo without having to
type everything out again it was like s
Oh with with two exclamation points
awesome
what's wrong one use my password for my
labs up and not for this machine
alright cool thank you so much for
giving me that command so quickly it's
been a really long time since I had to
use it so I didn't remember wait a
second
alright cool it worked that was really
fast I thought it was an error for a
second because it was so fast but let's
touch components and Woody's is gonna be
click heading
all right
so now we have this component and I had
I hid this earlier just to give some
more give us some more space I'll
probably decide it again if you use atom
this is actually really cool light I
used atom for years before I even
realize this shortcut command so like
you know the slash that shares a key
with the question mark I can't ever
remember which ones forward session
which was back slash that one
automatically comments something for you
but if you use the other slash the one
that's just below the backspace or
delete key depending on what it says on
your keyboard that one shows in hi it's
this little thing in the corner super
useful alright so so we're gonna do
let's take let's see if I have a
stateless functional component to just
steal from and I don't oh sorry
yawning I didn't have my normal energy
drink today before the stream so I'm a
little tired yawning said I had no no G
fuel to the hey alright so I'm I want to
try to type this component out without
copying because it might actually be
faster than trying to find one and I
think I can do it
so I import react
we can import reactant reacts and we're
gonna do Const and
what do we call this click heading
equals alright now I'm stuck now I need
to look all right let's see which one
did we do this with there use it with
this now we didn't
I don't know that we have any in here
because this one was one but then we
added I think we added State to it okay
I'll have to check my other my other
project I know I use them in my side
project that I'm doing for my course
right now so I will check that okay
Sebastian Sebastian has my back there we
go
props I couldn't remember what went in
there just FYI I've only probably built
maybe three stateless functional
components so far in my entire life so
that's why I can't remember the syntax
ok this probes and then just put the
brackets I can't remember I don't think
I need the brackets right
no I just need parentheses right okay
all right so that's all I need for the
beginning and then I need to export it
and I don't need this what I need my
that's what I want
Oh
click heading
why did i camelcase that when I needed
to capitalize this I'm gonna have to
rename it I don't know what I was
thinking
okay all right so that should work
I'm going to need to copy over sorry
h3
all right
so how h3 let's figure out what props we
need to pass in so we need to make a
click function here to handle the click
and change the state in our parent
component
and so in here
I'll put this so this is going to be
doing the same thing now on click what
we want to do is
and see
what am i I think I'm doing something
similar in another component so let me
let me look on my other screen I have my
other project open so that I can just
check this before I start fumbling
around okay
all right so that should be good
I know we're calling it clickhandler
here but I want it to be do I want this
no I don't want it to be because yeah I
want this to be reusable for other
things other than just showing content
so I don't want to call it that so I
guess we could just call it click click
Handler and we'll just so we'll have the
proper name the same thing
all right yeah and okay cabbies I see I
don't really even need this part right I
can get rid of that because I'm not
doing any anything other than just
saying there's a clique I don't need to
pass any data
okay all right so over here let's pull
in this component and click it
all right so click heading there and
click heading
all right so we definitely want to pass
as clickhandler
so will this a penny this
okay
and what else will we need we need to
pass the state down and then we need the
title okay
it's my content it's gonna be this
states content and then title
I'd off to be rendered this profs title
rendered okay so now
we can do
trops display content and drops title
all right
let's check it out what did I mess up
nineteen
I mess this up up here
copied over an extra one maybe that was
it this drops click Handa is not a
function
where I do that
Google Chrome thinks that my this error
message is is Catalan so it's s wants me
to translate it I wonder what it would
translate to interesting there we go
whoa
all right definitely messed something up
let me see
alright I'm gonna check
and checking the live chat quickly
alright let's say there's some
discussion in the live chat about
Lanie's commands
okay Kevin so yes I removed the
parentheses let's see okay I didn't
remove them here
okay I forgot - no wait I did but I did
pull the side one did I do this right
these props title render this props
title twice the title not being rendered
actually
yes you'd Sarah's in the lab chat hey
Sarah glad you could join us
okay I'm gonna need to probably wrap
this up and do a few more things before
I have to go I have a meeting with a
potential client later on for a side
thing I'm not sure if I'm going to do
the website is gonna be like a really
basic WordPress website I'm just not
sure that I'm really interested in doing
it but the person that wants me to do
the site is a friend from from high
school and she was friends with my wife
and so I felt bad because she hired
somebody to do this WordPress site and
she was gonna pay him $250 up front and
then $250 when they were done and all
they had to do the first step of all
they had to do was just redirect a
domain name which is no big deal and
then just kind of like make the theme
look a little bit better potentially
probably just find a better theme and
just apply that theme instead of the old
theme so it was really basic stuff and I
think it's been months I think it's been
since December and she hasn't heard from
this person and she already paid him
half the money so I feel bad so I still
kind of don't want to do the sightly I'm
not excited about doing the work at all
but I do feel bad and I don't really I
don't know we'll see I'll see what she
wants I'm at least gonna meet with her
and see what she wants for the site and
if it's something I can do really
quickly I guess I'll do it and maybe
I'll just say like whatever you're gonna
pay the other guy just pay me the rest
of it you know whatever's remaining
which will probably 250 and then and
I'll just finish up I did he did do some
work but I found like a test WordPress
site but it wasn't great looking
all right so as a as I was going off on
the little tangent there about my
meeting I was trying to look through
this and try to figure out why the title
is not showing up actually let me look
there's my dev tools that I want to see
what the what's being passed down to
these components spanning section click
heading
okay so it looks like it's not getting
the say it's not even showing up that
there's this title prop at all this
props title rendered
Oh
because it's not title rendered right
because we're inside of a component
we're passing the data in as title right
so let me see on our course page every
way I can just see where I'm using title
elsewhere right
this props title yeah I don't have to
put render that's the problem okay oh my
this should should fix the problem
yep there we go all right great so our
clique still work and now we've taken
some stuff out into a component awesome
so now we can replace all of our h3s
which i think is just to not not a huge
improvement but still helps I mean that
when it's all spread out like that
that's you know that's a number of lines
right there that's all right save that
just check make sure it's working
yep I mean
dear refresh just to check for sure okay
great
actually you'll see this why is there a
gap between this and this
that's weird I don't like that
that's weird
okay see all these other sections are 35
pixels tall and this one's 54 pixels
tall why is that it's not leave its the
site isn't being defined anywhere what
is going on
because this h3
you see this tip here probably
don't think I can see is there's it just
as classic let's take that so that would
be the second option here and it would
be this div right
well there's not there's no difference
that I can see here in terms of in the
code it looks the same but inin dev
tools they have different heights
oh I may have to wait and just figure
that out at a different time because I
gotta add a move on here alright so oops
where am I
kind of save I'm not sure what I edited
but save it click heading
all right so I got a switch to master
and make one update before I go yeah I
see sarah said CSS though yeah it's got
to be something with the CSS oh off to
look for that I don't want to do right
now sometimes if CSS stuff is just
pretty boring it's just a lot of like
clicking on elements and seeing what
comes up in dev tools so I don't think
that'll be that fun to have on the
stream and I got a yes it's um
I have a meeting in less than 45 minutes
so I need to get this done so I'll do
one of the things I have to do I can do
on stream and that'll be fine the other
thing is just me getting data out of
Salesforce like manually actually
copying pasting data and doing math with
in a Google sheet so that's not gonna be
fun to show and has nothing to do with
coding it's just a test that I wish I
could automate I can't get right now so
now let's go to the all right whether I
page you will be the courses page let me
refresh
yeah
okay so definitely I'm gonna make this a
link and I probably should make I'm not
sure that people will realize that this
is a link but I'm going to just make
that like they in the last meeting I had
that they wanted this to be a link but I
think I ought to put something maybe
right under here
have a button like this kind of button
but under here
I'm just not sure what to call it we we
threw out some ideas at the meaning on
what to call it and it never came to a
decision on what we should call the
button and I don't really have time to
talk to everybody and get them I'm not
even sure if anybody's still here I mean
it's after 4:00 on a Friday I'm sure a
lot of people are gone
I'd hate to call the button just say go
but I don't want it to be too long like
I could say if there's a Franciscan oh I
don't know if you'll have any ideas yeah
I know I uh yeah I don't know who's
gonna expect to click that's what I said
I didn't think anybody was gonna expect
to click on the title because we don't
really have clickable titles anywhere
else on this page and pretty much
nowhere except for the the blog the news
page do we have clickable titles so but
anyway they wanted to be clickable so
I'll just make it clickable but I do
need to put a button of this style up
here I think they they kind of wanted
like two buttons side by side they still
want this link to the PDF of more
information see the originally this was
supposed to be the link to go to
Franciscan at home calm and I only threw
the PDF in there as a placeholder but
now they want to keep it and so it was
gonna be really simple I was just gonna
replace the link but now I actually have
to do something else all right well I
may as well just throw some things in
here see what they look like so what's
this course is
all right so now we're back to the the
old version of the courses phase all
right so here's what we have
here's our button so let's put it here
let's see what it looks like
oops I put in the wrong spot
here we go this is where it needs to go
oh well not I don't really like that too
that much
all right let me see I'm gonna take the
live chat since I was see if anyone has
any ideas
Kevin in response to the Google I
mentioned I was doing some stuff in
Google sheets the Google sheet
automation is not a problem because
that's done in just JavaScript so it's
not really a big deal the problem is on
the Salesforce side of things is getting
the data out of Salesforce and into the
Google sheet the data that I need
because it's not just Salesforce it's
some like old plugin that I'm not really
thrilled with for Salesforce so I can't
even use like the normal documentation
for doing things in Salesforce also the
account that I've been given doesn't
really let me do that much so even if I
knew how to do it I probably don't even
have access to send that data to the
Google sheet and then I'm also getting
data I am getting data from another
Google sheet so I'd have to pull in data
from two different places in the sheet
which is not a big deal in terms of the
Google sheet but anyway so for
Salesforce that's that's the problem
like it it probably I mean in the long
run it would probably be good to learn
how to do that but I'm just I haven't
had a great experience with that
particular like plugin that we're using
I'm not really impressed with it and the
documentation for it is is terrible like
and actually non-existent for a lot of
things so it's just really hard to
figure out how to do anything I don't
know if anybody else has ever worked in
like higher education before but the
people who provide like software and web
services for our education like the
products are not good but I always try
to say positive things as I say it
nicely as I can but they're not good I'm
really really really disappointed and
everything even like the service like
asking them for things or like can we do
this or could you do it's just really
really bad and
even to the point where like when I've
actually gone in and changed code to
make it better and told them like hey
you know feel free to give this to your
other clients because I'm sure they need
to do the same thing too and we're not
talking like big deal stuff just simple
stuff like making making things
responsive so that they work on a phone
things that people expect to get and the
response was like no we're not gonna
give it to anybody like well are you
serious that's gave you this free free
code but and that the excuse basically
the whole reason was they're trying to
get people to pay more money for a
different product that was going to be
responsive and so they didn't want to
update their old product anymore even
though everybody was still in their old
product they had only sold their new
product to one school anyway sorry for
the rant it was just really frustrating
so if anybody wants an idea for an
industry where you could probably break
into and do a great job it would be in
services for higher education because if
you do a halfway decent job you will be
better than most of the services that
are out there right now
all right really the only thing that's
stopping me right now is from finishing
this is just figuring out what to call
this this button and normally I wouldn't
care so much but I know if I call us
something that the people in charge of
this project don't like I'm gonna get
called either in like an hour
when I'm at a meeting or tomorrow
morning or something they're gonna call
me and say can you change the name of
this button
I really want to say begin I think this
came up with like basically the idea of
saying something like begin is they
didn't like that because they didn't
want people to think that they're like
immediately starting a course I think
people are like smart enough to know
that they're not gonna immediately start
the course especially if we're gonna
keep this as learn more
I need to get rid of this this border at
the top maybe I have that margin top
yeah I need to get rid of that don't
need that margin there we go that looks
better
all right let me change this
there we go I just want to make sure
okay yeah it is it is in fact up so this
is the site that it's being linked to
the learning management site
[Music]
that's better than air
okay and let's make this title a link so
I'll grab this and
oh I did it again I went to the wrong
title keeps rolling up too much is this
one that I want now probably I need to
work with this color
it might automatically change the color
yeah dead so let me make this like text
all right cool
all right so now this can be clicked or
this can be clicked and I mean their
links they should work but I'm just
gonna click alright cool
and I wish they would have used the same
color favicon up here I'm not sure where
they even got that one I guess they made
it by they I mean like the company that
built this oh well I kind of wish that
they'd consulted me more about the
design so that it could have been
consistent so like they're little things
like a lot of like border-radius shadows
things like this like this is not the
behavior that happens on all of our
other sites when we have an interaction
with a button so yeah these are all I
don't know I mean it's not like the
information wasn't available about how
to do this there's lots of sites lots of
our sites that already use this and we
have a style guide so oh well I just
have this fear that at some point I'm
going to be asked to redesign all this
to match the University style and I've
been assured by my bosses that that's
not gonna happen but at one point I was
not supposed to be working on this site
either and that happens so I'm still
like not convinced that it's not gonna
happen and if it is gonna happen I'd
rather just know it now then have a
situation like this where I get pulled
in at the last minute and and do this I
would have liked to have had more time
oh well that works let's commit that
okay let's go to our servers
so that'll do its thing an update and
then we'll update the other server all
right and while that's working i'll
check the live chat and i need to keep
an eye on the time to make sure i can
update the data as well before I go so I
may not be able to get to everything in
the live chat so I apologize in advance
for that but I scrolled up about halfway
in the chat I don't think I missed
anything from the beginning
okay I'm gonna skip it it looks like
there's some discussion about them and
different things and some different
Linux commands stuff so I'm gonna skip
over a lot of that just for time and try
to get to everyone's questions even
though I'm sure there's some good
information within those conversations
I'll try to read them a different time
if I can okay so Sebastian says stop
your dev server go into the project
folder and delete the the dot next
folder check if your dev server works
okay
if it doesn't then clone the repo in a
new folder all right awesome I'm gonna
try that not right now but I'm
definitely gonna try that so thank you
John Hanson asks what happens when that
course page gets really long with some
kind of pagination or something some
other system need to be built into the
code it's possible right now it's the
course section is not supposed to get
longer so this is gonna stay pretty
fixed for now and this will pretty much
be be fixed but if that happens then I
guess I'll have to build something in at
that point it could be something like
that it could be potentially like
decreasing the font size and doing two
columns although on a small screen that
wouldn't it would still be large so I
have to come up with something for that
but I don't think it's supposed to grow
any
soon so so we'll see it actually it's
taken a lot of time to build like each
one of these because there's they have
to do like video production and editing
and everything for each one of these
courses and so they'll be along you know
a period of time of developing it before
this would ever get added so I should I
should have time to to do that if
necessary
okay Saad I thanks for giving me your
github account so that's cool I'll check
it out and then yeah let me know like
any specific questions that you have
about your code or anything you want me
to look at in particular send me a
message on on Twitter or I guess you
could put it in the comments in the
video I mean I'm more likely to see it
directly if you put it on Twitter so
that's probably the most reliable way to
get in touch with me
oh don't worry son don't worry about it
you're not bothering me not at all
yeah I just XANA you say you're out
dressing your dog cuz it got colder so
is that like legit your dog has a
sweater on now or something is that
Kevi and i just saw you're talking about
the I just noticed the component is not
stateless it needs state to know if it
renders the SVG rotated or not or it may
receive the orientation for the triangle
in a prop yes so it does receive it and
I'm sure you probably saw that
afterwards but yeah we just passed the
state from the parent component down to
the child in a prop and then the child
doesn't really need to to have its own
state which I can't see right now but
now that you're think you're saying that
I wonder I'm probably not gonna change
it now but I was just kind of wondering
like would it have been better no it
wouldn't have been but I was I was
wondering if the that component for the
headings should have had its own state
but I don't think it because I needed to
use that same that state to show and
hide in the other parent component so
it's better I think for that state to
live there especially if I put the
content sections into their own
component then that needs to be able to
pass that same state down to two
different components so I think it's
better to just keep it in the parent and
passed it as props to the children
components but I may be mistaken if
there's some good reason why I shouldn't
do it like that I would like to know
and you're asked if anybody has worked
with graph QL I haven't worked with
graph QL yet
I mean I've like mess around a little
bit with it but not not any serious work
with it but I'm really impressed with
what I've seen so far and I'd like to
use it more
Oh kevie and I see you're saying that
for a debug tip render the props inside
a pre tag in the stateless component
cool thanks for that tip Santa said
never worked for your distant family or
friends
yeah I'd I know I like all the clients
that I still have better recurring
clients are all either family or friends
and it's like you can't what am I gonna
say tell them I'm not gonna do this
anymore I mean I guess if I had somebody
that I don't know I don't know I like
keep thinking maybe I should just get
like subcontract the work that's
somebody but even then like it's not
enough money for it to be worthwhile for
anyone like I have a client right now
that's a family friend and last month I
didn't even send him an invoice because
they only owed me like 12 dollars I
thought it's not really worth my time to
even create and send an invoice for $12
so I'll have to see but I think this
month they're gonna owe me less than $30
and I'm like thirty dollars a little bit
better but is it really worth my time to
actually like take time on a Saturday or
something and you know go into the
invoicing software and send it I don't
know it's but it's it's hard to quit B
it's hard to to get rid of a client that
is a friend or family member so I just
never should have done it anyway I
should have said No
Leonard's ass how often do you stream
this type of project is this ongoing in
parts and actually it looks like
everybody already answered that question
all answered for the sake of people
watching this maybe later on I do stream
Monday through Friday
usually at 2:00 p.m. Eastern Time
occasionally I have to change the time
and occasionally I'm not able to stream
on a day but I usually will put it on
Twitter like earlier in the day to let
let everyone know whether there's a time
change or whether I can't do it
okay I'm seeing all the stuff now that
everyone said about the like the weird
spacing between those two headings so
thanks for that I'll take a look at that
later on too and try some of those
things
okay I see Sarah that you had said maybe
don't make it a button just a link so
sorry I didn't see that earlier so at
this point I'm just gonna keep it as a
button because I'm running out of time
but maybe at some point I'll see how it
looks like just as not a button in just
the length
hey Jeremy so if you're watching
yesterday you may remember that Jeremy
had a job interview today and Jeremy
just came in the live chat and said that
he got the job so awesome
congratulations super excited for you
so yeah awesome if if you're able to
come back to a stream in the future
please let us know how the jobs going
that's really cool
yeah Patrick I just so you said about
the button animation very 1999 and moves
in a very incorrect way yeah I agree I'm
not really a big fan of the button
animation on I guess I closed it out but
earlier I had the site yeah this button
I'm not really sure about this button
animation because it the way it graze it
out usually when something's grayed out
like that that means that it's not
clickable like it's not it's disabled so
it's a little bit odd and it you know
moves sideways and down which it makes
it look like you've already clicked it
when you when it's down so it's just
it's it's not the animation doesn't
really make sense for the purpose of
that element so it's a little odd and
then on top of that it's just this is
not then you know we have a certain way
of doing animation on buttons that we
use across the board on all our sites
and this is not that way so I think it's
better to keep it consistent
okay then I just saw that about the the
project yeah I'm not sure let me so I am
I'm gonna meet with the fraud I'm gonna
meet with the client here it's very soon
and actually I'll see what they want and
and then I'll see if it's worthwhile if
it's if it seems like maybe I'll let you
all know if maybe one of you are up for
doing it and Zanna maybe all depending
on how the meeting goes maybe I'll send
you a message on Twitter and let you
know if if it's even worthwhile but that
would actually be cool it's I think it's
gonna be a really easy project like I
don't even think it's gonna involve much
coding at all it's just gonna be like
customizing a wordpress theme most
likely and that's you know that's that's
not really a big deal so anyway I have
got to go now
so I need to get this data updated in
about five minutes and then go
luckily my meeting is only a few minutes
away by car so I should still be able to
get there on time but Kevin hey how's it
going Kevin's here from Trinidad so glad
you could join us
sorry I'm about to end the stream so
sorry you came in right at the end but
you'll be able to watch the recording in
just a few minutes it'll be available on
on this channel in the free code Kent
Channel so anyway thanks everyone for
all your help today
and let's see oh this is Friday right so
have a great weekend and I'll see
everyone on Tuesday so no stream on
Monday and not working on Monday Tuesday
I'll see you if anybody has any other
questions he's helped with anything
Twitter is the most reliable way to get
a hold of me so you can message me on
there otherwise I'll see everyone on
Tuesday and
[Music]
again thanks so much for watching and
all your help have a great weekend